well let's talk about laws we'll talk
about sound policy and we'll make it
about guns i'll take i take the
opportunity to advance our gun
discussion because i like to we have the
story from timcast.com west virginia's
crime rates decline after state adopts
constitutional carry law fbi data
indicates a steady decline in violent
crime since 2016 when the policy was
approved by the state's legislature so i
walk into a gun store and i'm like uh so
what do i have to do to buy a gun like
you got to fill out your nick's form the
national instant criminal check system
takes forever
yeah it depends sometimes you can put on
the delay list but sometimes it's 15
minutes i'm always on the delay list
because daniel turner is the most boring
name in the world and there are there
are like 33 000 daniel turner's and i'm
always delayed they got to go through it
so well so sometimes they can be like
come back in a few days or they might
just be like we're you're being
researched give us a few minutes but in
west virginia i'm like okay so i didn't
do i need anything no no i can just take
this weapon right now yeah i can put it
on my belt oh yeah you sure you don't
want to do concealed carry i was like i
can yeah you just put it right inside
your belt and i'm like really yeah it's
west virginia constitutional carry you
can't do it outside the state and they
do recommend you get your concealed
carry permit mean you take the test you
get approved and all that stuff because
it does benefit you that is your
background check so you don't have to go
through knicks anymore you just walk in
and buy
but this is the this is the perfect
example
people in west virginia live in a very
different world from people in new york
city in chicago
so when you when you see national level
politicians like basically what we're
just talking about is that there are
senators and there are congress people
for the nation they they actually
literally represent one state or one
district but they fundraise off of
everyone in the world
so for those that missed the previous
segment we're basically saying like some
guy in virginia back in the day would go
to dc
hear about a damn breaking in new york
in new york state and be like i
represent west virginia i didn't hear
anything about this i don't know
nowadays you'll get big corporations
trying to get votes to crush new york
state law by getting a federal law to
like supersede it or by getting support
from other places so this is what ends
up happening you get democrats who are
like we should ban guns i'm like okay
you know what i'll say this first of all
second amendment so you can't just do
that but i hear you if you live in
chicago
and you live in that world i don't live
there anymore i can tell you what it was
like living there
it doesn't make sense for you to pass a
law based on chicago's problems on west
virginia because in west virginia their
crime went down when they told everybody
feel free to carry a weapon around and
the example i always give people when
they're like you know uh we we obviously
you know uh we have different properties
here for tim cast
and there are people who you know come
from cities and they're worried about
guns and stuff
i i i tell people look
when i go outside and i'm in new york
you you've you guys have been in new
york i imagine of course yeah used to
live there born and raised yeah were you
scared crossing the street
um
it depends upon what what stage of my
life oh it's just like what but like
hitting by a car oh god no no we played
in the streets jay walk in the street
break open the fire hydrants and spread
imagine this
in chicago in new york you'll want
you'll be driving around you'll see a
fire hydrant open up and spring in the
street right you've seen those before
sure it's in the middle of the street
are you noticing they were basketball
people would put basketball hoops up to
the street they would play when a car
comes car and they'd move
in chicago we would skate in the street
in a
car and we'd move
imagine looking at this gigantic massive
metal hurtling at you at 35 to 40 miles
an hour or whatever depending on what
part of the city you're in and and then
freezing
there are cars everywhere what do we do
when i see people in west virginia
carrying guns
you don't even think about it i don't
think someone in the car is going to
veer off the road and slam into me
sometimes it happens and i don't think a
guy's got a gun is going to pull out
just shooting randomly but there are
people who live in cities who who feel
this way and all of a sudden now they're
using the weight of the federal
government to go after states where it
makes no sense this is one of the
biggest problems we're facing right now
and it's why even sarah silverman in my
opinion is saying peaceful divorce
because if we're at a point where you've
got democrats being like we would like
to pass laws for new york but for the
country that makes no sense it's i'll
tell you what the problem is when you
see politicians running for federal
office they want to be in congress like
aoc or anybody else they are running for
federal office and they go i'm going to
clean up this town if you vote for me
we're going to reduce crime rates and
improve schooling and get funding for
our university or you know and
hold on
you're not a local politician you're
running for federal office you're not
you're not representing the district's
interests in terms of how they how they
spend their own tax funds you're talking
about going to congress and voting on
war and budgets which will affect your
district but when they're like i'm going
to clean up this town no you're not
you're going to dc you're going to be
voting on cleaning up afghanistan or
coming back and cleaning up
syria
you want you want to change those issues
you vote for local politicians what
happens now is people are running for
office on local issues nationally
and then they're saying we've got a gun
problem in chicago so we should ban guns
for people in west virginia yeah
that makes sense do you think that these
politicians and lawmakers started off as
people that had local pride and then
they just got corrupted as they got
involved in the process or do you think
that they were just chills from the
beginning
i think i think um
kirsten gillibrand is a great example of
that she was a congresswoman from
upstate new york moderate democrat
uh
hillary clinton moved on uh her seat was
vacant and she got the job and now
kirsten gillibrand is as left-wing as
chuck schumer remember when she was in
the shop she was she had a approval
rating from from the nra she had a
positive approval rating i bet you ask
her now she would probably be a hundred
percent anti-guns in all form because
and that's what separates her from i
think as someone like senator bernie
sanders because vermont doesn't have a
huge city bernie is only rural so bernie
actually on guns is either pretty quiet
or actually probably not that bad but if
you're a senator from a state like new
york kristen kirsten gillibrand and
chuck schumer know they just need to win
new york city they don't care about
albany utica
you know something like schenectady no
one cares about those places same with
california same same with with illinois
right but if you're from a kind of a
state that has like
some city but like it's a rural state
vermont the two guys from from
connecticut the two guys from uh uh um
uh new hampshire you are
you are spelling out why we need the
electoral college absolutely when you
look at states like new york illinois
they say in illinois i don't need to win
anything but chicago yeah
and that's all becoming all of america
and that's the ethos of my organization
powerthefuture.com is the the divide in
america used to
the divide in america growing divide i
think in my personal philosophy i should
write a book on this is between urban
and rural and we were always a rural
country that had big cities but it used
to be when i was born it was 55 45 and
in my lifetime that has flip-flopped and
now the majority of us live in cities so
that's right and city people are well
thank god but city people are making
policies for the country look at the
green new deal look at the the the
high-speed rail and no combustion engine
that is written by someone who thinks
like a a girl
aoc who has only known the city she is
not thinking of someone who is from
rural west virginia so she says we'll
just get rid of the combustion engine
and you say well in alaska
a lot of people like a lot of people
have a little tiny airplane because
that's how they get to the grocery store
like it is not uncommon to jump in your
little tiny plane and they buy planes
for what you buy suvs forty thousand
dollar you can buy a used plane i think
maybe they don't really have their
license but it's alaska no one cares
they fly they land they go to the
grocery ban the combination
i think i read somewhere that if we shut
down oil all fossil fuel production
within this year you'd get like 60
million dead within a few months oh
absolutely uh probably more than
actually i think it's like within a few
days 60 million would die mostly because
they'd be unable to power refrigerators
all the diabetics would instantly die
because their insulin would spoil and
then you can't transport food you can't
drive anymore so all of the energy
transportation that grows food
transports food and makes the water work
and like
where they say that we're addicted to
fossil fuels it's not that we're
addicted it's that our infrastructure is
built upon it it's not an addiction it's
a it's an energy requirement for
sustaining this level of yeah and they
have immigration they have no idea how
farming works how ranching works how
manufacturing works so they will say
something like the peta folks or the
whatever folks like this is cruel what
you do to animals and could we and
should we treat animals humanely as we
absolutely we should and we should
always strive to be better but the thing
is that you live in the upper east side
of manhattan and you think food is going
to whole foods and buying stuff in my
package and you have no idea what it
took to get that thing look at this this
this is
water in a plastic bottle that was bro
this is not possible but for fossil
fuels
i was talking to someone during the
primary
and it was uh i'm sorry not the primary
yeah it was it it was on lockdown so
like primer was a lot throughout
lockdown right wasn't it yeah and i
mentioned something like if we shut down
the economy
how eventually we're going to run out of
food at the stores and i had someone who
was pro like a ubi guy say what are you
talking about we can just go to the
store to get food when we need it and
then i said
if we do ubi
and people don't work and don't make
stuff
and people aren't farming then where
will the food come from and they're like
the store what do you mean oh god
i hope you cut that person
on twitter it was twitter and i'm like
there are people who are literally
sitting there thinking that like one day
like a little loaf of bread just appears
on the shelf and slowly starts growing
yeah and then you take it and then
another one responds yeah they had to be
trolling you too oh they gotta be good
[Music]
please be troll think about how stupid
the average person is yeah i don't
realize half of them are stupid when i
was in first grade we took the iowa
basics and i got nothing in the 99th
percentile so i was like okay i guess we
all got in the 99th percentile because
that's the easiest thing that just
they're just as much questions stuff
they already told me yeah but that's
just not how society works people failed
it's like but they told you this i can't
remember it was the most obvious i was
like here's all the answers now write
them down and how people couldn't get it
i just don't them and when people are
looking at why food prices are growing
up and and covet has a lot to do with
that oil prices has a lot to do with
that inflation but but as you were
saying with this guy who doesn't know
where food comes from we paid
and working in a slaughtering house is
not glorious work right it's probably
really brutal um i'm sure it pays okay
but you know it's not that you're not
gonna make a huge living it employs a
lot of ex-convicts right it employs a
lot of people with records because
you're slaughtering cows um and i know
this having talked to people who do this
who own these companies for a living and
they were making more to stay home the
last year and a half with kovid and so
now you are bringing in beef that is not
getting processed that we're throwing in
the garbage i have a friend who has five
barns and each one of them has 75 000
little baby chicks that they raise to a
certain size and then the tysons or
companies like that come and take them
off and they process the chickens and
that's why there's always chickens in
the grocery store
but because of kova that was all shut
down and the chickens got too big and
all of the machines that process
chickens the chicken has to be this big
or this big and now the chicken grew an
extra two months and well you know what
they said and this is my and his mom was
genuinely in tears they said go into
your barns and turn off the ac and close
the door wow and they s and that was
what they had to do and that was the fda
that and then what throw them away and
then you throw them away that was the
fda that was like and that's what you do
hundreds of thousands of chickens that
are perfectly healthy why because the
government said they're not essential
workers so now people like why is food
so expensive government thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you